i've had a lot of girls on the show and
typically they don't want a virgin
i would you like a virgin i've always
wanted to try dude
i'm too old now but i would like because
i feel like if you're a virgin like
you're probably waiting for someone
special and like if you were to i think
it goes for me it goes both ways it's
like
oh like i'm the first
to try the novelty can i just add
something can i just she said try it
in the chat they're like they're wiper
what i'm saying like
like you would want a virgin man for a
long-term relationship yeah so you would
prefer to teach a man how to get sex in
the bedroom 100
i'd rather like him like um a bit i
think it's more attractive if a man is
too confident in chatting to me
leave because i know you've chatted to
10 girls in this club already like or
this bar whatever like it's too you're
too skilled at this right i want someone
who comes to me like
my last ex like the first kiss we had he
he was like shaking a bit i was like you
okay he's like can i kiss you and i was
like this is the sweetest thing i think
it's the sweetest thing when someone's
like really nervous because obviously
like it's not like they don't do it all
the time so i don't believe you yeah
i don't believe you
it was well cute
it was just like really yeah
yeah do you know what it is
not attractive
i think this generation of women have
become so masculine yeah
that some feminine behaviors in men
actually turn them on
wow that is that is what i believe i
believe that so many women of this
younger side this generation have become
so masculine that
men acting like women now turns them on
and it's very weird to me because it's
like i don't think it's acting like
women
this is an exhaustive of course
typically you're going to have more
masculine energy
you ever think about when feminism
advocates for men it only advocates for
men to benefit them because they want
them to be more emotionally available
say that again whenever feminism
advocates for men they only advocate for
men when it benefits them because they
want men to be more emotionally
available so it's really about the women
it's not the man so big i would ask you
i would argue that being emotionally
available is good for everyone yeah and
not just the man especially if you
choose to have kids an emotionally
available man yeah it's a lot better
than an emotion i mean and you would
think that from a woman's point of view
yeah yeah because that that's like yeah
okay
i've got a caveat to that so
in an instance i agree with you but more
so than anything a man shouldn't be
emotionally available to his woman
because a woman more times than not
doesn't understand the complexities that
he goes through he should be emotionally
available to his male friends who he
should seek guidance from hundreds in
order to deal with the situations
that
will come within his relationship and
i'm saying male friends that are
actually good and conducive to what he
wants and that way what happens is a
woman will feel emotionally
comfortable to come and open up to her
man
because
she he's he can be her rock yeah
i feel like women think they can see
that you see that guy that's a bit
nervous that wants to kiss you and i was
like oh like oh my god i'm shy you see
that guy there you know that guy's not a
protector exactly somewhere in somewhere
in you you know that guy's a [ __ ] he
don't see a spider you do you do you
know that guy is not confident he's not
confident um he doesn't really he
doesn't get girls he's not the type of
he does he's he's not the type of man
he's not the type of man that you step
out in public where they said okay this
guy's gonna protect me he's not that
dude so at the end of it at the end of
the day it might be a novelty for a
certain point of so for a certain for a
certain time right but i think in the
long run you wouldn't even respect that
man
or second guy i'm just curious
so the one you laughed
that's the reason i started dating him
and it's not that if he was like i've
there's boys who are very confident and
that turns me right off like it's the
complete opposite it's just a lot of
times like what guy the feedback because
i listen to men talk a lot and so a lot
of times what they say is like when what
don't listen to what women say because
they'll say things watch what they do
and so so and this is the case where
you're saying this man was emotionally
available but the result was still you
laughed it doesn't mean yeah it doesn't
mean he was emotionally available like
that's a complete like
i don't know what's going on that's not
right the thing is the thing is women
grossly underestimate the man they think
they can actually solve his problems but
like
especially for feminine exactly
especially from an emotional point of
view like you really don't and can't to
a certain extent understand the plight
of a man and how what it's like for
people to only value you based on what
you can provide on a continual basis
yeah another man can understand that
because he's in the exact same situation
so if a man can actually you know
process his emotions using his other
male friends who are let's say further
down the line let's say these men have
successful marriages he can then go back
to his let's say newly married wife and
be like okay cool this is how it's going
to be this is he can he knows exactly
what to say and how to move and how to
maneuver right because he's gotten that
tutelage from older experienced men who
let's say are in successful maritime
relationships really do you think that
women should not run societies
why because return our rights baby
because you wanted to feminize men yeah
and you think you think feminine men are
gonna listen china and russia are still
around yeah a bunch of feminine men
running around ain't gonna be good for
society because when it's wartime you
can have a bunch of [ __ ] running
around saying oh my god baby could you
go out and do the war no like what the
hell you need masculine men for an
actual reason and i think when women are
in charge they use their emotions more
so than they use their logic and so they
ask men to be like them which is why
when a woman women generally come to men
to have a conversation and say oh my god
babe you're not happening at work today
and the man just like
because he you should talk to your women
friends like that i get it right but men
do not operate the same way you so how
would you
love your wife or whoever you're dating
to operate with you in the home
how would i do what how would you prefer
her to operate with you in the home
if she's uh just provide value and be an
asset yeah but how so vague like well
okay cool like okay so if you want to
would you talk to her at all
okay so so this is the thing i'm writing
it down okay so women women have a way
in which they speak to each other yeah
so you see earlier when you said the
communication wasn't communicating yeah
right i'm like what the [ __ ]
like so women have a certain language
that they have between one another right
and so what you have to understand is
men operate
mentally and oh what the hell is that
like men operate differently right when
it comes to um
understanding and when it comes to
processing information but very logical
like like i said if i'm gonna talk to
you bro i'm gonna tell you this this
this this this boom done right women
like when a woman speaks to you she told
me about her feelings first all right so
i was anyway i was on my period right so
you already know
and it's like it's a whole thing and i'm
and i'm just like
i ain't got men generally don't have
time for that type of conversation they
generally don't and i know you you're
probably thinking this is misogynistic
this is sexist but but it's real like
men don't operate we don't speak like
you speak we don't communicate like you
communicate yeah would you update a babe
call i'll see you later then right
exactly
talk to me
i'll
it's interesting what you said because
like you use the word misogynistic and i
think a lot of women conflate you know
someone trying to let them know that
their actions will have long-term
consequences and ramifications with you
hate me because right now i'm feeling
like you hate me no i don't hate you